et dans cette course aux élections
législatives on connaît dorénavant les
noms de tous les candidats dans les
différentes circonscriptions yvelinoise
tv fil 78 intéresse la plus
particulièrement au sud des yvelines
nicolas bonsoir bonsoir six
circonscriptions qui nous concerne
directement et un constat un nombre de
candidats et candidates plutôt important
oui au total sur ces circonscriptions il
y à 87 candidats c'est beaucoup plus
qu'il y a 5 en 2012 il y avait 72
candidats au départ sur le même bassin
c'est donc 15 de plus et la palme de la
circonscription entre guillemets la plus
convoitée revient à la deuxième celle de
vélizy et d'une partie de versailles
ils sont 17 au total à se battre pour la
députation
ces quatre de plus par exemple que sur
la 11e circonscription où il n'y a entre
guillemets que treize candidats mais en
moyenne vous le voyez wilfried on se
situe à chaque fois largement au dessus
de la barre des 10 candidats ce qui est
de compliquer le choix des électeurs à
noter enfin que seuls deux députés
sortants deux députés sortants ne se
représentent pas françois de mazières
sur la première circonscription et henri
guaino sur l'aa 3e françois de mazières
qu'on a aperçu et qui préfère se
concentrer sur sa municipalité et henri
guaino qui lui en revanche n'a pas reçu
l'investiture des républicains pour la
3e circonscription la parité en tout cas
n'est pas forcément respectée une
nouvelle fois oui une nouvelle fois
c'est une constance elles sont 30 et une
à se présenter sur les circonscriptions
qui nous concerne ce qui correspond à un
peu plus de d'un tiers de femmes
candidates et tout en bas du classement
on retrouve la première circonscription
avec seulement trois femmes pour onze
hommes la parité est respectée
finalement que sur la 12e
circonscription avec cette femme et cet
homme et signe d'un vieux système qui
semble se perdurer tout de même
l'égalité respecter en revanche et les
suppléants ou 43 femmes feront campagne
aux côtés de leur candidat et il y aura
une campagne plutôt musclée sur certains
territoires
en effet on peut retenir de deux
exemples qui vont sûrement animer ces
prochaines semaines à commencer par la
10e circonscription où le député sortant
jean-frédéric poisson candidat de la
droite se reposer à aurore bergé
candidat en marche transfuges
des républicains les hostilités ont déjà
largement débuté sur les réseaux sociaux
et via les médias entre les deux
candidats et puis il faudra suivre aussi
le match retour entre guillemets sur la
11e circonscription entre le socialiste
benoît hamon et le candidat de la droite
jean michel fourgous était déjà les deux
candidats finalistes en 2012 et au vu
des résultats de la présidentielle il
faudra aussi compter sur l'inconnu en
marche nadia et et le candidat de la
france est soumise mathurin lévis est
donc une possible bataille à 4 qui se
dessine sur cette circonscription où il
merci nicolas je rappelle que vous
pouvez retrouver toute l'actualité de
cette campagne sur notre site internet
est également sur notre application
mobile et puis chaque jour 1 re
quotidien au cours des différentes l
édition de nos journaux d'information
avant